Siz beni görüyorsunuz Ama ben sizi
buradan o kadar güzel görüyorum ki bu
heyecan Eminim bu sunuyla birlikte size
geçecek bir ricam olacak cep
telefonunuzun ışıklarını açarsanız bu
çünkü interaktif bir sunum olacak
sorduğum sorulara telefonunuzu
kaldırarak yanıt vermenizi isteyeceğim
huzurunuzda Hacettepe Üniversitesi tıp
fakültesinin dekanı olarak bulunuyorum
çok ama çok onurlu bir görev
beni bu göreve öneren beni bu göreve
kabul eden Sayın rektörüm Umarım bu
konuşmadan sonra pişman olmayacak çünkü
keyifli bir sunum olacak aynı zamanda
mezun olduğum Ankara Üniversitesi
rektörüm de pişman olmayacak Umarım
keyifli bir sunum geçecek Ben düşümü
yaşıyorum
Asistan olduğum yıllarda Ben Hacettepe
Üniversitesi'nin yönetiminde yer
alacağım dediğimde arkadaşlarım ben de
dalga geçiyordu Sonuç ortada Bu görev o
kadar onurlu bir görev ki
bu onurlu görevde
atanızın huzuruna çıkıp imza atabilecek
kadar gururlanıyorsunuz onurlanıyorsunuz
[Alkış]
Ama bu onurlu görevin müthiş bir havası
var Siz bunu yaşayamıyorsunuz
Sevdikleriniz aileniz eşiniz dostunuz
daha çok havasını yaşıyor
atandım bir süre geçti sabah
kahvaltısındayız çayın bitti
kızımdan rica ettim yanıt bende kan
kızıyım karımdan rica ettim yanıt Ben
dekan karısıyım kös kös kalkıp kendi
çayımı aldım Dolayısıyla etrafınız
sizden daha çok böbürlenecek ama bir
teselliyim var Aziz Sancar hala evinin
çöpünü kendisi döküyor Dolayısıyla
Kısmetse Nobel konuşmasına
[Alkış]
biraz rakamdan bahsedeceğim boyun bir 94
konuşmanın içeriğinde Çünkü bu rakamlara
ihtiyaç var 52 yaşındayım 46 numara
ayaklarım var
29 yıllık bir evlilik
ayakları üzerine basan düşündüklerini
üslup hatası yapmadan ifade edebilen iki
kız çocuğunun babası olarak huzurunuzdi
baktığınızda şu an gördüğünüz ürünün Bir
de geçmişi var
sezeryan olarak doğmuş bir bebeğim Annem
rahmetli beni doğururken periton
enfeksiyonu oluyor ölüm riski var Benim
babaannem tek çocuğunu anneme ve annemin
ailesine vermiş olmanın hışmayla bu
kadın ölürse bundan sonra Bu çocuklara
ve bana kim bakar deyip oradaki
doktorlardan hemşirelerden babama yeni
eş seçme güdüsüyle davranmış bir
babaanne birazdan göreceksiniz ama sonuç
Annem o süreci geçirdi Ondan sonra
aralarındaki ilişkiye Siz karar verir
devam ettik mutlu bir çocuktum Çünkü
sevgi ile büyütüldüm fotoğrafta
gördükleriniz babam annem anneannem
ablam abim ve ortada Ben yalnız buradaki
tek mutsuz kişi benim
tahmin edin neden sıra bana da gelecek
mi Çok şükür o gün kurtardı ama bu
fotoğrafta çok daha büyük bir dram var
koyu renk elbiseli olan Benim anneannem
Bulgaristan'daki eziyetten kaçarak
Türkiye'ye sığınmış olan bir Bulgar
türkü çok zorluklar çekilmiş bugünkü
ülkelerin en büyük sorunu olan göçün
Vatan terk etmenin
vatansızlığının ne olduğunu yaşamış bir
Anneannenin torunu olarak da
huzurunuzdayım o kadar korkmuş ki
çocukken beni hep yanında yatırmış Ben
yanında olmadığında da bir yastık koymuş
ondan destek alarak hayatını idam etmiş
bir anne gördüğünüz gibi duygulanıyor
devam edelim Az önceki babaannem bir
Anadolu kadını
Kahraman İnebolu'nun yetiştirdiği bir
kadın yine bolluyum
sırtına halısını alıp Çayda yıkadıktan
sonra 3-4 dakika içinde yukarıya doğru
sırtlanabilecek kuvvetli bir kadın ama
benim Tıp eğitiminin temelinde
öğrendiğim bir kadın
bizim evimizde İnebolu'da şişenin içinde
sülük vardı şişe almaya
bir yerimizi belirlediğimizde et basardı
içinde prostatlendim vardır şişi yarayı
iyileştirir tavukların gırtlağına bir
şey kaçtığında ilk operasyonu ondan
gördüm Keser sonra da yine iplikte
dikerdi
mutlu bir çocuktum TED Ankara Koleji
mezunuyum Çocukluğum sırasında yaşadığım
iki kültürün çok etkisi var
oturduğumuz semt Cebeci o dönemin
memurlarının orta ve alt gelir
seviyesinin oturduğu bir yer Cebeci'de
sokakta oynadığım kasabın manavın oğlu
benim arkadaşlarım
aynı zamanda İnebolu olduğunuz için
Kastamonulu olduğunuz için memleketten
gelen pastırmayı yediğimde ertesi gün
çivi oynarken çamurda gaz
çıkarttığınızda arkadaşınızın Oh mis
gibi pastırma koktu diye gıpta ile
yaşadığı bir yer aynı kültür neden Kara
Kolejinde okurken sıra arkadaşım
Millet Meclisi'nin başkanının kızı
çevrede müthiş bir gelir seviyesi yüksek
topluluk var Hafta sonu çok farklı
şeylere şahit oldum doğum günlerine
katıldım İyi ki de oldu çünkü sahip
olduğunuzun kıymetini o yaşlardan
öğrenmeye başlıyorsunuz
fotoğraf orta son olsa gerek burada
vurgulamak istediğim Benim ayaklarım
bakar mısınız genelde kumaş pantolon
altına takım elbisenin altına kösele
giyilir Ben mecburen spor ayakkabı
giyiyorum Çünkü o dönem benim ayak
numaramı göre kösele ayakkabı standartta
yok ama babam çareyi buldu
İnebolu'da bana ayakkabı yaptırdı
gördüğünüz yumurta topuk ayakkabı
modeliyle 3 gün okula gitmişliğim var o
kadar eleştirildim ki tekrar spor
ayakkabıya döndüm soldaki otobüs
belediyenin otobüsü kullanırken iki yere
en konforlu enbiyıp kısımdı benim için
ön havalandırma ızgarası arka
havalandırması yarısının bulunduğu yer
uzundum Çünkü o dönem uzunluğundan
dolayı rahatsızdım o dönem ayakkabı
bulamamaktan rahatsızdım ama biz
olduğumuz gibi kend imizi kabul
ettiğimiz sürece hayat çok ama çok güzel
sadece ve sadece farklı pencerelerden
bakılabileceğini hatırlatmak isterim
özellikle genç arkadaşlarıma
gördüğünüz fotoğraf Bu benim yazdığım
Rahmetli babamın maaşından kooperatif
olarak girdiği Yalova'daki bir site
yanında da o dönemin en büyük inşaat
firmasının yaptığı sistem var sitede
Fenerbahçe'nin o dönemki başkanının
yazdığı var helikopterler geliyor
tekneler gidiyor müthiş bir hayat
o dönemin meşhurlarından bütün
şarkıcıların geldiği bir Gazinosu var
Muazzez Abacı Emel Sayın o dönem gördüm
yazların bir kısmı burada geçiyor sonra
yaz tatili babaannenin yanına gitmek
lazım inebolu'ya gidiyorum
İnebolu'da gördüğünüz En öndeki kırmızı
aşı boyalı ev bizim evimiz orada
yapılacak olan faaliyetler balık tutmak
denize gitmek bahçede oynamak ve Kur'an
kursuna gitmek
yazları bir Kültür şoku bir başka
Anadolu kültürü çok şükür hepsini
harmanlamış bir ürün olarak bugün
karşınızdayım her farklı kültüre karşı
lütfen gönlünüz kalbiniz zihniniz açık
olsun insan her yerde aynı insan çünkü
bir düştü neydi düş Hekim olmak
istiyordu Hekim olmak için çalıştım
Ankara Üniversitesi tıp fakültesini
kazandım Şahane
[Müzik]
Türkiye'nin en iyi Tıp fakültelerinden
bir tanesi öğrencilik hayatı çok iyi
gidiyor çok iyi giderken Tabii gençlik
var hareketliyim o dönem modellik
yapıyorum Kendi param kazanıyorum
Tercüme yapıyorum O dönemin banknotunun
en yüksek parasını alıyorum Bu
gördüğünüz de hayatımda gittiğim tek ve
ilk Ev partisinde pasta servisi yaparken
ben
o partide eşimle tanıştım
o partide Ben eşimi Kandırdım ikna ettim
derken meğersem beni gördüğünde
söylediği şey ben bu çocukla evleneceğim
sonuç hala evdeyiz Ben bir şey
yapmıyorum
Hayat size ne getiriyorsa onu
yaşıyorsunuz sizin dışınızda da sizin
adına Verilen kararlar olabilir lütfen
sorgulamayın itaat et
yıllar geçiyor
sonrasında bakıyorsunuz bir anıyla
karşılıyorsunuz bu para
eşimle tanıştığım gün telefon numarası
vereceğim
Türkiye'm Cumhuriyeti Merkez Bankası'na
minnetimin Fatih'e olan sevgimin en
önemli unsuru Kağıt yok cebindeki kalemi
Taksiden aldın üstüme telefon numaramı
yazdım bin liranın üstünde 126 ile
başlayan O sayede eşimle bugünlere
geldik Dolayısıyla pratik çözümler
üretme odaklı olun soruna kalmayın Kağıt
mı yok çözdük sonuç karşınızda
devamına bakın okuyoruz
okurken çok başarılı bir öğrenci miydim
hayır notu alıyorum geçiyorum parmak
iziden 60 almam gerekirken 59 dakika
kaldım Bir yıl tekrar ettim Çok üzüldüm
bugün yaptığım Hoca olarak hiçbir
öğrencimi bir puan yüzünden bir sene
tekrar ettirme
[Müzik]
bu Çünkü sadece o öğrenciye ceza değil
bu ülke ekonomisine yaptığınız
müsriftlik yanı sıra Bugün de hiçbir
zaman 59'luk çalışmam niye 70'lik 80'lik
çalışmadım kabahat gene bende mezun
oluyorum
fotoğrafta gördüğünüz kadın benim
kahramanlarımdan bir tanesi Kayınvalidem
sahneye davet ediliyor 5'erli onarlı
çağrılıyorsunuz diploma veriliyor beni
tek çağırdılar
utansam mı endişelensem mi bir aksaklık
oldu mezun mu olamıyorum derken
Kayınvalidem karşıdan geliyor o dönemin
Rektörü sınıf arkadaşı abla vermek ister
misin diplomasını damadın Tabii ki geldi
O an düştüm şaşkınlığı heyecanı ve tek
başına diploma almanın arkadaşların
arasındaki utancı hepsi bir arada bugün
düşünüyorum İyi ki olmuş çünkü
kahramanın elinden bu diplomayı aldığım
için bugün huzurlarınızda Tıp Fakültesi
dekanı olarak konuşabiliyorum birazdan
onun hikayesi geliyor evlendik
ilişki sürdü mecburi hizmet var Eşim
devlette çalıştığı için eş kurasına
katılacağım
evlendikten sonra
2 ay sonra mecbur hizmet kaldırıldı 24
yaşında öğrenciyken evlendim Ama hayatta
her plan size göre olmak zorunda değil
adaptasyon yeteneği kişilerde başarı ve
mutluluk Sırrı Çok şükür o günde adapte
oldum Çünkü bugün karşınızda başarılı
bir hikaye anlatmak için var
Duştan bahsediyoruz değil mi İktisat
yapmam lazım doktora yapmam lazım
anatomi doktorası yaptım uzmanlığımı
almak üzereyim tezimi vereceğim
fotoğraftaki en az Gülen kişi benim
uzmanlık bitiyor Ne yapacağım kadro var
mı eşim gebe çocukla ilgili endişe
yaşıyorum yanı sıra burada bilmediğim
bir şey daha var bedelli askerliğe
gideceğim döneceğim Yardımcı Doçent
kadrosuna tanıacağım
yaptığım nedir hepsini Hallettik
Aracımı sattım bedelli askerlik
parasının tamamını yatırdım ki terhis
belgesi alayım doçentlik yardımcı
doçentlik kadrosuna tanıyayım
İstanbul'da kura Çektim Her şey şahane
bedelli olduğunuz için ne yapıldığı
bilinmiyor Ero olarak yaptım sırtıma
postalıyla basan bir yüzbaşının
İstanbul'da bana çektirdiği eziyeti
yaşadım baktım olacak gibi değil bir
tanıdık bulduk komutana çıktık komutan o
günden sonra beni reviri aldı buradaki
mesaj Şu arkadaşlar Bulunduğunuz makam
Mevkii Asla kimseyi ezmesin Çünkü beni
komutana çıkartan sırtıma basan o
Yüzbaşı komutanın odasının kapısının
önünde benim çamurumu temizliyordu
Lütfen mevki ve makam nedeniyle
insanlara eziyet haksızlık vicdansızlık
yapmayın çok iz bırakıyor hala duygu
yoğunluğunu hissediyorsunuzdur
[Alkış]
yıllar geçti akademik yükseltmeler her
şey yolunda Fakat ben de enerji çok
başka bir şeyler yapmam lazım bir gün
biriyim ev geldi bir yarışma başvurusu
başvurdum bilimin anlaşılır şekilde
anlatılmasıyla beni Türkiye'nin bilimsel
seçtiler Aynı yıl dünya bir maç seçildim
diğer Bir yarışmada farklı alanlara
kaymak iletişimin ne kadar güçlü
olduğunu size kanıtı nereye kadar
İngiltere kraliçesinin huzuruna çıktım
ürün olarak Türkiye ziyaretinde ve
gururla söylüyorum bunu ülkemi temsil
etmek devletimi temsil etmek harika bir
duygu İnşallah sizlere de nasip olur
enerjim çok yetmiyor kadavra masası
tasarladım anatomisi ne yapar ödül aldım
bu yaşta alabildiğim en yüksek ödül
parasıydı kısmet Eşme harcamakmış o
günden beri bana olan sevgisinde ayrı
bir artış olmuştur mutlaka gene etmedi
gazete köşe yazarlığı yaptım bu da
yetmedi önce moderatörümüz Esra hanıma
konuk oldum baktım Bu iş Beni sardı
kendi televizyon programımı yaptım
Lütfen ufkunuzu açık tutun Ne iş
yapıyorsanız severek yapın ki yıllar
sonra öğrencilerinizde verdiğiniz bir
pozda bile Yüzünüzdeki gülümseme daim
olsun bütün bunları yaparken Bu
gördüğünüz CV'yi karşınıza gelirken Rol
modelleriniz kahramanlarınız var
bu Kahramanlar kimler bir tanesi benim
babam
İnebolu Devlet Okulu Kastamonu Devlet
Okulu İstanbul Teknik Üniversitesi
devamında Ankara hukuk fakültesi 4 dili
öğrenmiş bu cumhuriyetin bu devletin
yetiştirdiği bir birey Dolayısıyla
devlete olan inancım babamdan ve üründen
dolayı gelir lütfen devletinize inanın
Türkiye Cumhuriyeti çok güçlü bir devlet
her bir bireyini kişiye yetiştiriyor
Buyurun size örnek
bir başkası
diğer kahramanım Kayınvalidem Sağdaki
fotoğraf Türkiye'nin ilk kalp naklinin
yapıldığı güne ait
Kayınvalidem bu ekibin içindeki üç
ihtisaslı kardiyolog olarak görev yapmış
bir kişi bu Cumhuriyetinin kadınına
verdiği önemin belgesi karşınızda nasıl
sizlerden de bir kaç cerrahisinde imza
atacak bir kişi dünya çapında yetişir mi
şu kadar tereddütüm yok inşallah yıllar
sonra karşılaştığımızda gelip bu
duyguları bana ifade edersiniz
aynı kahramanın bugünkü durumu 88
yaşında ve hala Bana sevgiyle bakıyor
beyni ile ilgili sıkıntıdan dolayı
sadece beni tanıyor Bu da büyükleri olan
saygının büyüklere olan minnetin yıllar
sonra size yansıması Lütfen sizden yaşça
büyüklere hep saygılı olun bir
dediklerini iki etmeyin yanınızda varken
de kıymetini bilin sonrası çok geç bir
kahramanım daha var
gördüğünüz slayt Normalde kalp atım
sesiyle karşınıza geliyor bu yaşamı
gösteren bir sinyal ama durduğu anda
ölümsüzsün
ölümsüzlük bana göre kişilerle değil
eserlerle işte bugün sizin huzurunuza
beni çıkartan Eser bu fotoğrafın sahibi
tanıyanlar lütfen ışıklarını
kaldırsınlar
tanıyamadınız değil mi ben tanıtayım
Profesör Doktor İhsan doğramacıydı
Kendisi iki üniversiteyi hayal etti
kurdu beni sizin karşınıza getirdi saygı
ve minnetle andığın bir kahraman
sıkıştığında özgeçmişini biyografisini
okuyorum kopya çekiyor Bir kahramanım
daha var bu kahraman
bizleri sizlerin huzuruna getiren bu
cumhuriyetin kahramanı
[Alkış]
birçok şey söyledim bundan sonra ben
değil sesi açık olursa ifadeleri o
söyleyecek Buyurun hep birlikte
dinliyoruz
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
gençliğin Birinci vazifen Türk
istiklalini Türk Cumhuriyetini ilelebet
muhafaza ve müdafaa etmektir
valinin yegane temeli budur
Bu temel senin en kıymetli hazinendir
atomun sözlerinin üstüne söyleyecek söz
yok
onun kurduğu bu Cumhuriyet onun bizlere
verdiği bu bağımsızlık sayesinde Biz
bugün bir aradayız
lütfen düşününüz Neyse inanarak
yılmayarak severek düşün peşine teşekkür
ediyorum beni dinlediğiniz için
[Alkış]